نعم ، نعم ، جون حسنًا ، ما كنا هنا
لمدة ثلاث ليالٍ في هذا الموقع حيث استؤنفت
هذه العملية
وبالتأكيد كان بين عشية وضحاها القصف الأشد
والمطول
لهذا المخيم ، لم تعد
المدينة التي نفقدها نحن في فقاعات ،
هذا مخيم  ربما نصف
ميل مربع وفي الأساس كنا مستيقظين
طوال الليل مع
آسف دائم لقصفهم طوال الليل
والمعارك الطويلة بالضربات الجوية واستمرت
حتى الصباح ، لذا فأنا أعلم أننا
قلنا هذا مرارًا وتكرارًا لهذا السبب
أنا أضحك أن هذه ربما تكون
المعركة النهائية النهائية بشكل صحيح ، لكن
بالتأكيد هذا يمثل ما
يبدو أنه الدفعة الأخيرة لمحاولة استعادة
أنها قطعة صغيرة جدًا من الأرض نعلم
أنه في الـ 36 ساعة الماضية أكثر من
ثلاثة آلاف شخص بما في ذلك
استسلم مقاتلو داعش وغادروا البلدة
مما يترك
الجهاديين الأكثر تشددًا أولئك الذين عقدوا العزم على الموت
بدلاً من الاستسلام.